or as one of this country's most
recognized personal finance experts
experts
she went from waitressing and making
$400 a month to becoming a leading
stockbroker Orman is a two-time Emmy
Award winning TV host and the author
nine New York Times bestsellers she's
releasing a new edition of her
best-selling book women and money it
reveals a new plan to take control of
your finances Suze Orman it is so good
to see you again
didn't you get a kick out of Kristin
Wiggs I loved I thought she was kind of
down on the audience once yeah I was
doing it and everybody was watching me
watch her yeah I was like yeah I was
like Suze Orman and her jackets but
let's see so you that was Kristin used
to say them and you're wearing a jacket
today $5 but this book came out in 2007
yes and you said the read it's more
important now than ever before because
women still have issues with their money
and you you talk about the me to
movement now I do what I realized is
that I've always said self-worth equals
network does that mean and it means that
you have to value yourself because if
you don't now what happens is you make
money you give it away you think your
money is for everybody else but not
yourself and women always do that and so
as the me to movement started and I
realize women finally have a voice
they're speaking up the unspeakable
mm-hm
they still need to find a financial
voice yeah but you look at the data as
you point out and women on average lose
over a million dollars over their
lifetime for settling for the salary
that they're offered and that's why they
need to find a voice that values
themselves you know there's a law money
when you undervalue use yourself the
world undervalues what you do and I know
a lot of women who have used their voice
and have not gotten that raise and it's
not about getting a raise it's about
feeling powerful in your life and why
don't you get a raise because you can
use your voice but that doesn't mean
that you have power this book is all
about right here and right now on what's
happening to women for them to be given
actual steps in many ways internally and
externally for them to
they use their voice there's power
behind the voice so what does that mean
exactly those if somebody's listening
give them a tip oh my god there's so
many tips in there but the first thing
you have to do is you really need a
financial empowerment plan which is what
I call it in in the book you need this
you need your eight-month emergency fund
you need a will you need a trust you
need those things but more than those
things even you need to know who you are
you need to be able to deal with money
within your family
it's money is just a manifestation of
you I thought it was interesting you
said money doesn't buy happiness and
it's been in my experience only rich
people say that I'll tell you money will
not buy you happiness right but lack of
money sure will make you miserable you
go all right so I've never said the goal
isn't to have money but it because you
need money let's face it everybody you
need money and to be able to live and so
how do you get money what do you do with
the money that you make what can you do
because when you're powerful over your
money even if you have a little money
you're happy some of the common mistakes
that women make with money they're still
making today even after you've given so
much advice on this topic
there are still co-signing loans for
their children there's still tape
letting their kids go to schools that
are too expensive and taking out loans
for them to do so and then their kids
stamp to whatever the biggest mistake
women are still making is that they are
saying yes out of fear of what other
people will think about them versus no
lot of love for themselves they'll say
yes I'll lend you this money yes I'll
give you this
yes I'll do this for you versus no I
don't want to because I want it for
myself and Susie how does this play out
in relationships oh my god the number
one reason I am needing help but but I
got oh so you need to go from zero to
some times it does but one out of two
people who get married end up in divorce
number one reason as arguments over
money what's very important is you want
to hear an interesting fact is that
women who
more money than their male spouse lie
about how much money they make so that
their spouse doesn't feel bad and men
who make less than their wives lie and
say they make more so so you who makes
the money does not rule the roost yeah
you said that shouldn't be the power
dynamic yes so much in this when you're
dating you said it's important that you
talk about money yeah that when you're
dating and it becomes serious the first
thing you want to know about him is his
FICO score yes because how it's money
what which is your credit serve you're
right because how he treats money also
reflects on how he treats himself and
how he treats you yeah if listen if
somebody doesn't want to talk to you
about money and there isn't a
conversation about it it's over right
then and there and if you look at
somebody's credit reports in their FICO
score you know I have a same then the
same really is FICO first then sex I'm
not going to go about it and how do you
bring that up yeah well unfortunately
we're gonna have to leave it there
that's a good place to leave it it's a
memorable place yes exactly let the
record show John you are not thinking
about a divorce or no divorce talk in
your house no there's not Suze Orman
thank you
Michael the new edition of women money
is on sale now